this is a production of Cornell
University thanks um uh first time I
think I presented here so uh thanks for
giving me the chance I'm going to tell
you a little bit about some of the stuff
we work on we work on a lot of different
projects uh so I've sort of talked uh
I've chosen something that relates
pretty specifically I think to plant
micro interactions but just to give you
the overview we're very interested in
what microbes are doing in soil and
because microbial communities in soil
are tremendously diverse and most of
those organisms are still
uncharacterized you know our focus is
first and foremost on that diversity and
understanding what drives it so that's
questions of
biogeography uh where we're thinking
about how microbes get to where they are
and why they're successful in those
environments so those can be large scale
biogeography uh and what drives that but
also in terms of Agriculture that's
management so things we do very much
influence the success of dispersal the
fitness of the organisms we want to know
why that is what makes them successful
or not um we're also interested in
evolution because microbes can evolve
kind of quickly and how they change will
affect both whether they're successful
in that environment as well as what they
do in that environment so specifically
we're interested in how their genomes
change and how that change relates to
the diversity and so our big question
here relates a lot to Al Gene transfer
so how are they exchanging information
who are they exchanging information with
how is that dependent on dispersal or
Community composition and what does that
do to their function in terms of their
functions we want to know how their
diversity affects what they do um we're
very interested in the carbon and
nitrogen cycle and both of these things
relate to soil Health uh and so we're
interested in that as well so in terms
of carbon we're interested in how
microbes transform carbon in the soil
and how they contribute to soil organic
matter formation so most of our Sol
organic matter is made up of dead
microbes and so the growth and death of
microbes is super important to that um
and also microbes contribute a lot to
that nitrogen cycle as well in terms of
making nitrogen available transforming
that nitrogen um and ultimately that
brings us back to plants because plants
are the Big Driver of these systems so
whether it's biogeography or management
or their evolution or their function
plants are constantly pushing on the
microbes and the microbes are of course
pushing back uh and so the more we get
interested in for example the carbon
cycle the more we realize that what
microbes do in terms of the carbon cycle
is driven by the plants and so that's
what I'll tell you a little bit about
today specifically some work we've been
doing to get more involved with
plants and so the phenomena I'm going to
be talking about today something we're
just starting to really look at in my
lab is called priming and so the idea of
priming goes back a long way it's the
idea that microbes are interacting with
soil organic matter so the carbon that's
stored in the soil which is basically
the basis of soil fertility right plants
do not have the enzymes that they need
to get access to this just like you
can't eat you can't digest plant
material without your microbes
enzymatically a UK carot just doesn't
have the diversity of enzymes that
microbes have and so I have microbes in
my gut that help me eat plant material
these plants interacting with microbes
in the soil to get access to the
nutrients in the soil right so what
priming is is if I add a little bit of
carbon to the soil microbes I change
their activity and that could be a
negative priming result in which case I
add some carbon to the soil that
activates these microbes and they cause
more so to be mineralized than I would
have expected based on the amount of
carbon I add so basically I'm priming
the pump just like if you're priming a
water pump on the other side you can
actually get positive priming so
sometimes when you add carbon to soil
you cause some of that carbon to be
stored permanently or semi permanently
as s so so presumably that's because the
microbes grow and when they die their
little dead bodies are contributing to
the accumulation of carbon and stable
pools so depending on how we add the
carbon and the environmental conditions
we can get one or the other response and
the literature is a mess you know it's
it's hard to know exactly when you're
going to get one or the other people do
the same thing in different experiments
and come up with different results and
so there's not a good strong mechanism
as to what's driving this and of course
this is just adding carbon but in the
real world this would be driven by
plants through either riseo deposition
or exitation plants have the ability to
release some of their photosynthetic
carbon through the root system and
presumably hypothetically they could be
driving negative or positive priming and
the reason for this primarily might be
that by getting a an advantage by
activating negative priming the microbes
go after the Soom that's mineralizing
carbon CO2 but then that also releases
things like n and p that are locked up
in that so the plant would have an
ability to push on the gas pedal try and
get more nutrients by activating
microbes
hypothetic that's the kind of phenomena
we're interested in so I got interested
in this with because we're in a great
School of plant Sciences so I had
collaboration with Taran barley in
horiculture who was working with uh a
priming experiment she was doing out at
arnno fars with maple trees and at the
same time just by coincidence I was
doing some work collaborating with or at
least I had taken over for a project
Jean Madson had started in microbiology
and Jean as many of you know passed a
few years ago because I did a lot of
similar research to him I took over some
of his projects when he when he died and
took them to completion and it just so
happened that these two things
intersected in a very interesting way so
the experiment Taran was doing was
taking soil from the maple trees and
then a typical priming experiment you
add different carbon sources to that
soil now this is without the roots
present and if you add glucose you don't
really see significant priming she was
adding aromatics because she knew that
these roots were producing aromatic uh
uh phenolic acids and aromatic acids in
their exid dates and she wanted to know
sort of what was happening why were they
doing this and was this relating to
priming so she added benzoic acid as
well as combinations of different things
and she did the experiment with other
kind of aromatics as well I'm just
showing the result for benzoic acid but
benzoic acid induced significant priming
and then you had this sort of
synergistic effect when you had glucose
and benzoic acid together which was sort
of interesting and so the question is
sort of what's going on why is this
happening so she was able to show that
the priming is in no small part not
surprisingly driven by changes in enzyme
activity so beta galactosidase activity
um the phosphatase activity netal glucos
glucosidase activity all of these were
accelerated by the presence of this
benzoic acid so that's what we would
expect with this negative priming we
also see that the priming was driven by
a change in community composition so
here this is an ordination where each of
these spots is a different Community
composition when the spots are close
together that means the communities are
similar so here's where we started we
add different substrates and then over
time we see those substrates cause a
shift in the community but we see that
the benzoic acid and benzoic acid plus
glucose really caused this different
effect from everything else and that
different effect was associated with
higher amounts of priming as it turned
out she uh worked with us to have some
help analyzing the Cal communities in
these data and a lot of this difference
in the community that was driven by that
benzoic acid was affiliated with this
one group of organisms Brooker ACA so
they went through the roof and this was
super exciting to us because at the same
time we were working with this data from
Jean Madson and we saw some of the same
organisms coming up so when am I at
seven minutes s minutes
and8 um
so
uh so so he was doing stabil isotope
probing experiments he happened to be
using 13c parah hydroxy benzoid so we
could track that into the microbes what
we saw from him was that these parabal
area uh which are members of barpal der
dominated this activity they were
exactly the same microbes that Taran saw
we isolated some of these guys and the
thing that's very interesting about them
is they're loaded with ring cleavage
enzymes so they're really good at taking
apart soil organic matter they're loaded
with phosphatase activity so they're
really good at
solubilizing uh inorganic phosphorus
they also tend to associate with the
roots of a lot of plants so if you've
heard of beta risia these uh nodulating
bacteria that are not in the alpha
proteo bacteria they're parabal area so
these guys have these tight associations
with plants and we think that plants are
facilitated their growth I'm going to
jump ahead the model we have is these
microbes really like sugars so if you
give them sugars they grow like crazy
they really like the phenolic acids and
they're able to eat a lot of them if you
give them the phenolic acids they grow
like crazy but if you give them the
sugars they don't induce their ring
cleavage activity so if you give them
sugars they'll grow a lot but then if
you hit them with the phenolic acids
they'll turn on the ring cleavage and go
after this organic matter so we think we
have a mechanism whereas the plant could
control what the microb is doing because
not everything can eat these phenolic
acids so if you have the phenolic acids
these guys will be able to grow maybe
not anything that can grow using sugar
so the plant can control who's there and
who's actually going after this organic
matter and maybe the plant's able to
regulate this priming
activity participant uh any questions in
the
room part the community is you're
tracking uh bacteria or
so the par the parab area are oh the
question was are they bacteria or fungi
so the pararal areia are bacteria yeah
uh an interesting aspect of this is that
related organisms to these parabal areia
are often highly enriched in the
hyphosphere so there's the potential for
three-way associations like plant AMF
bacteria associated with the AMF because
when people look they're often
co-occurring with some of these fungal
networks my question related more to the
analysis microbial diversity and how it
shifted was it bacteria populations only
in this particular experiment we were
only tracking the
bacteria these am the the the the maple
trees that were the subject of this
often host AMF
so we think that AMF probably are part
of that
equation okay well thank you Josh for
spear hitting this and thank you Gillian
for the invitation to be here it's
really a pleasure as Josh said this is
my second month on the job but I'm
really happy to share with you some of
my thoughts about my program and some of
the research directions that we'll be
taking so I am a vegetable breeder and
the program that I'm starting here
Cornell's focused on tomato and eggplant
breeding with the emphasis on the
Northeastern United States and New York
especially uh to give a really high
level overview of the objectives of our
program you know really broadly they are
to discover the genetic basis of traits
that are of agronomic or consumer
importance in our region to model
strategies for the implementation of new
predictive breeding Technologies like
genomic selection that have been really
widely adopted in agronomic crops
species but are kind of lagging behind
in in vegetables for several reasons and
finally to release cultivars with with
high yield excellent quality and
resistance to the prevalent diseases in
our
region so as a faculty member with an
extension appointment um I have been
enjoying spending kind of my first
several weeks on the job getting to know
my colleagues in Cornell Cooperative
Extension and and just learning a little
bit more about the nature of tomato and
egg plant growing in New York state and
uh I've found it both amazing but also
as a breeder kind of daunting just how
much variety there is in terms of how
these crops are grown how they're
marketed and uh what what Market classes
and crop types are grown so the last
time the USDA released statistics for
New York State there were close to 3,000
Acres of tomato production in New York
that includes everything from the open
field to high tunnels which are very
important in our state uh both for
season extension and for crop protection
and also uh in greenh houses I believe
there are over 200 Acres of tomatoes uh
underglass uh in these you know really
high-tech uh facilities that are
operated by some of the world's um
largest and most sophisticated uh
Greenhouse tomato production companies
in in our
state uh tomatoes are sold to Wholesale
Distributors they're sold at produce
auctions they're sold at csas and
farmers markets they're grown in gardens
and in urban farms and urban Gardens um
everything has grown from cherry
tomatoes to heirm tomatoes to the modern
red
slicers um and in terms of eggplant uh I
found it amazing how much variation
there is in crop type there including
types that you know many people here are
largely unfamiliar with uh including the
African eggplant which is uh not even
the same species as the Italian plant
that we're familiar with but it's a
really important part of the diet uh in
many regions of the world and I think
their opportunities for new markets for
for New York
Growers so you know ac across the board
uh across all these different production
systems and Market classes uh there's a
really strong demand from uh Growers for
disease resistance in varieties and just
as an illustrated example I took this
screenshot from Bayer's uh web page this
is one of their uh tomato varieties and
if you look at the disease resistance
codes which you might be familiar with
if you look at seat cataly LS uh there's
somewhere between eight and 10 different
uh disease resistances that are stacked
in this one variety and again you know
uh this is something that is both
amazing to me but also really daunting
as a breeder just how many different
disease resistances you need in a
variety in order to be commercially
competitive
nowaday so the the reason that breeders
have been able to to do this amazing
work is really due to a very rich Legacy
of uh collection and characterization
and curation of uh wild tomato species
uh almost all of the disease resistances
that are available in modern tomato
varieties come from a wild relative of
tomato uh in in many crops you know we
often hear people talk about concern
about erosion of genetic diversity as a
result of of modern breeding compared to
some of the land races and traditional
varieties that were grown years ago it's
incredible that in tomato is actually
the opposite if you look at the
varieties that are available nowadays
there's more genetic variation in that
domesticated tomato gene pool because of
all the variation that breeders have
brought in from Wild relatives
predominantly driven by breeding for
disease
resistance so when when I think about uh
how I want to contribute to this Legacy
of breeding for disease resistance and
solcius crops one thing that I keep in
mind and and I think this is an audience
that won't argue with me too much on
this is how important it is to have some
understanding the Dynamics of the
pathogen populations as well I think
there are many examples uh of this in
tomato one of them that's particularly
relevant to our state due to the high
tunel production it's importance here is
tomato leaf mold that's a disease that
is really a limiting factor for high
tunnel tomato production although it's
not really a concern in the open field a
project that I was involved in with a
former labmate of mine Martha Sudan who
who led this work uh we we characterize
the genetic diversity of of strains of
tomato leaf mold from our region uh one
of the important takeaways that we found
uh from some race typing experiments was
that all the strains that we collected
were of two races race zero and two uh
for me as a breeder it's important to
know this because there's one gene
that's really used predominantly in
tomato breeding for resistance to tomato
leaf mold that's cf9 which thankfully
confers resistance against both of these
races that we see in our region but else
in the world there reports of that
resistance breaking down so my takeaway
moving forward as a plant breeder is
that even if our populations in our
region at the moment don't necessarily
warrant it I think the proactive
approach is to start stacking some of
these other resistance genes into our
varieties with the expectation that
given the usage of high tunnels and the
exclusive use of this one resistance
Gene we we may expect to see that
resistance breaking down in the
future um tomato leaf mold is a good
example because it's a a pathogen that's
been very well characterized at the
molecular level in terms of uh its H
pathogen interactions there are many
more examples of pathos systems where we
really know next to nothing about the
nature of the variation in the pathogen
that that uh influences the ability of
certain strains or populations to cause
disease and varieties and others not to
uh so in earlier work that I did in my
PhD I was interested in kind of
answering this question a little bit in
phytop capsy which causes phyto light on
pepper one of the things that we did was
take a collection of isolates challenge
it on different pepper varieties and
conduct a genome light Association study
to try to find those genes that are
involved in verin on different varieties
what we ended up finding was that the
lowside that we had the power to be able
to map um tended to have an effect on
veillance on all the peppers that we
tested which seems to suggest that in
this pathos system perhaps the strongest
effect interactions are race nonspecific
or variety nonspecific and there are
smaller effect interactions that have
more of a race um specific
nature so in terms of uh future
directions for my research program um as
I've been talking to extension
Specialists and colleagues in pathology
and Growers uh as soon as I mentioned
eggplant everyone tells me vertican welt
resistance which seems like a pretty
good indication that that's something
that should work on um so I'm planning
on studying the the inheritance of
resistance to verticy Will and eggplant
wild relatives I'm interested in how
that performs against the two species of
verum we have both of which are
controlled by a single Gene in tomato uh
my my predecessor in tomato breeding at
Cornell Martha mudler did fantastic work
on folar uh fungal disease resistance um
but it's predominantly available in a
small number of genetic Backes um so I'm
interested in understanding how we can
use markers related to those genes to
predict that resistance in a diversity
of other uh Market classes of tomato and
then lastly you know as I kind of
alluded to the the the Paradigm for its
matal breeding has been uh backcrossing
and introgression of qualitative major
effect resistance genes the pathogens
that breeders have been slower and less
able to make a big impact on are those
diseases that are controlled more by
quantitative resistance Loi I'm
interested in working on some strategies
uh using some genomics assisted breeding
approaches to breed for resistance to
those diseases as well uh so thank you
all for for your time uh at the moment
my lab is myself and darinda young who
has been instrumental getting the lab
set up as as my lab manager and I'll be
recruiting students and a postu and a
technician as well thank
you okay great thanks so much any
questions for
great six
weeks within the tomato leaf pathogen
you said there race one and two or two
different races is there much genetic
diversity within a race or between races
uh there is question yes the question
was in the tomato leaf mold pathogen the
nature of the genetic variation within
and between
races um we yes there there was quite a
bit of genetic variation we found
evidence for both sexual and asexual
reproduction and it didn't seem like
that genetic variation was necessarily
partitioned uh by race which kind of
makes sense given that these race
nomenclatures are governed by maybe a
single single team I question
about so in terms of think
about are there
distinct
ches uh that that that's that's a great
question um sure so the question was uh
uh the specific disease uh issues
related to Urban agriculture as as
opposed to more traditional open field
agriculture that's something that I'm
hoping to learn um I I I don't know
exactly there there there definitely are
very strong environmental influences on
the diseases that are um uh relevant in
tomato production in in green houses and
high tunnels things like leaf mold and
powdery mildew can be problems whereas
they tend not to be issues in the field
so I expect there to be similar uh
challenges in urban environments as well
Bill one another is the origin Center of
origin
plant it's it's been I'm sorry I keep
forgetting yeah the question was the
center of origin of eggplant uh and
there's actually been really recent
research on this um the the hypothesis
according to this recent study that came
out is that uh the center of origin is
southeast Asia uh it migrated from there
to India where it had kind of a
secondary domestication event there and
then migrated from there to Europe and
Africa this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu